su médico puede recomendarle una cirugía
laparoscópica para reparar una hernia
incisional o ventral una hernia ventral
puede verse como una protuberancia
anormal debajo de la piel de su abdomen
la protuberancia puede estar en sus
intestinos que están ubicados dentro de
su abdomen
una membrana fina llamada peritoneo
cubre la mayor parte de sus órganos
abdominales incluyendo sus intestinos
sus músculos abdominales rodean el
peritoneo y su piel cubre la pared
abdominal
estas tres capas amortiguan y protegen
sus órganos internos
si usted ha tenido una cirugía abdominal
en el pasado puede aparecer una hernia
la paro atómica ventral en el lugar de
la cicatriz de la cirugía
aquí su intestino empuja a través del
lugar debilitado en el tejido entre sus
músculos abdominales creando una
protuberancia debajo de su piel el
tejido peritoneal que rodea el intestino
herniado se llama saco de hernia
si su hernia no se repara pueden ocurrir
complicaciones por ejemplo la abertura
de la hernia puede atrapar una curva de
su intestino que puede bloquear de
manera parcial o total el pasaje de su
contenido
lo que resulta en una condición llamada
obstrucción intestinal puede
experimentar síntomas tales como dolor
vómito y constipación
la obstrucción intestinal puede causar
la estrangulación una condición en la
que el flujo sanguíneo de su intestino
se corta
como resultado un segmento de su
intestino puede morir
antes del procedimiento se le colocará
una vía intravenosa y posiblemente se le
administre un sedante para ayudarlo a
relajarse se le administrara anestesia
general que lo dormirá mientras dura la
operación se le insertará un tubo
respiratorio de manera temporal por la
boca hasta la garganta que le ayudará a
respirar durante la operación es posible
que también se le coloca un catéter en
la vejiga para drenar la orina
para comenzar el procedimiento su
cirujano realizará una pequeña incisión
en su abdomen luego colocará un tubo
pequeño llamado puerto dentro de la
incisión y luego su cirujano bombear a
gas de dióxido de carbono a través del
puerto en su abdomen expandiéndolo para
poder ver sus órganos abdominales más
fácilmente
luego su cirujano realizará otra
incisión cerca de su ombligo e insertar
a otro puerto pequeño
a través de este puerto su cirujano
insertará un laparoscopio que es una
cámara pequeña que proyecta imágenes en
un monitor de tv para guiar el trabajo
del cirujano
mientras revisa la superficie interior
de su abdomen su cirujano y realizará
dos incisiones más e insertar a dos
puertos más luego su cirujano insertará
instrumentos quirúrgicos angostos a
través de estos puertos para comenzar la
reparación se quitara el tejido de
cicatrices de operaciones previas si
fuese necesario
y luego su cirujano cortara el saco de
hernia lo que permitirá que su intestino
regrese a su ubicación correcta en su
abdomen su cirujano luego coser a un
trozo de malla sobre la parte débil en
su pared abdominal para impedir que el
intestino resbale por la abertura
su cirujano examinará el área en busca
de sangrado u otro daño y realizará las
reparaciones necesarias se dejarán el
lugar una válvula del puerto durante un
corto tiempo para permitir que todo el
dióxido de carbono salga del abdomen
finalmente su cirujano quitará los
instrumentos y cerrará las incisiones
con suturas o grapas después de la
cirugía se les retirará el tubo
respiratorio y el catéter y se lo
trasladará al área de recuperación para
controlarlo le darán medicamentos contra
el dolor si fuese necesario cuando pueda
beber líquidos le quitarán la vía
intravenosa
podrá irse a casa el mismo día o
permanecer una noche en el hospital para
ayudar a curar su hernia deberá evitar
levantar objetos pesados agacharse y
doblarse durante varias semanas después
del procedimiento